[Music]
now during my interview with Governor
Newsom I asked the governor about the
indictment of Donald Trump and his
relationship with the former president
take a look
Donald Trump I'd be negligent if I
didn't get your reaction to what
happened in the news said and I say that
as an American I can imagine friendly
with him why as you know I didn't have a
close fist I had an open hand we
actually had incredible relations during
covet right it was incredible he was
played no politics during covet with
California by none whatsoever it's a
fact and by the way I've got a lot of
critique from the left by saying that on
the French Laundry just so it was a dumb
it was a terrible mistake it wasn't
illegal it was wrong and I totally
violated the spirit of what I was
preaching and it was wrong and I own
that I owned there and you know what for
the grace of God no one else has ever
made a mistake I guess I did I own that
okay everybody makes mistakes however
that was a dumb but it was done and I
own it so I don't need to be reminded of
it close quarters no mask and I'm like
all right it was by the way right I
think it was your birthday party right I
was a good friend's 50th birthday party
this the wrestler was legally open it
was done you said on Dianne Feinstein
just to get one piece of news and that
you will
um if you have to replace her you have
set a criteria only an African-American
woman why is it right that was the right
thing to do we lost with the Kamala
Harris we lost that representation it's
important it's historic uh I appointed
the first Latino in California's history
37 of the State uh Latino 39 uh percent
of the state I thought that was
important I think it's in the criteria
just be the best person well there's
plenty of them African wear it's a
limitless this is the best person and
just not have a criteria last question I
think I think one four yeah I stand
corrected
um and you want to see the full report
can you afford that I mean are you
really going to pay that money Ronald
Reagan did reparations for the Japanese
I'm asking for this it's beyond it
doesn't have to be in the frame of
writing the check reparations comes in
many different forms but one cannot deny
these historical facts and I really
believe very strongly we have to come to
Grace how do you justify people that I
had no connection generationally to
anything to do with slavery how how do
you justify them having either a lower
standard a higher standard or paying
money for something that they or their
family were not responsible I totally
look I you understand that deeply
understand that I deeply understand do
the math on the 1.4 okay look we want us
to level set you had a group the last
two years that is making a series of
recommendations that was one of many
recommendations you guys ran with that
over and over and over and over again
still today I haven't even seen the
recommendation when you see the
recommendations and you're inclined to
support the money I put out a statement
saying reparations is more than just
about money that implies a deeper
rationalization of what is achievable
what's reasonable and what is right and
that's the balance that we'll try to
advance
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else